what is the top obstacle to Peaceful
coexistence of Israelis and Palestinians
let's talk about the big question of
Peace in this part of the world
well I I think the reason you have
uh the Persistence of the uh
palestinian-israeli conflict which goes
back about a century is the persistent
Palestinian refusal to recognize a
Jewish State a nation-state for the
Jewish people in any boundary and that's
why they opposed the establishment of
the state of Israel before we had a
state and that's why they've opposed it
after we had a state they opposed it
when we were we didn't have Judea and
Samaria the West Bank in our heads in
Gaza and the opposite after we have it
doesn't make a difference it's basically
the persistent refusal
to recognize a Jewish state in any
boundaries and I think their tragedy is
that they've been commandeered for a
century by leadership that refused to
compromise with the idea of of Zionism
they believe that the Jews deserve a
state in this part of the world the
territorial dispute is something else
you have a territorial dispute if you
say okay you're living on this side
we're living on that side let's decide
where the border is and so on that's not
what the argument is the Palestinian
society which is itself
fragmented but all the factions agree
there shouldn't be a Jewish State anyway
okay they just disagree between Hamas
that says oh well you should have it you
know we should get rid of it with Terror
uh and the others are saying no we
should also use political means to
dissolve it uh so that is that is the
problem so even as part of a two-state
solution they're still against the idea
well they don't want a state next to
usual they want a state instead of
Israel and they say if we get a state
we'll use it as a springboard to destroy
the the smaller Israeli state which is
what happened when Israel unilaterally
walked out of Gaza and effectively
established the Hamas State there they
didn't say all good now we have you know
our own territory our own State Israel
is no longer there let's build peace
let's build uh uh you know economic
projects let's say enfranchise our
people no they turned it into a
basically into a terror Bastion for
which they find uh 10 000 Rockets into
Israel when Israel left uh Lebanon uh
you know because we had terrorist
attacks from there then we had Lebanon
taken over by Hezbollah terrorist
organization that seeks to destroy
Israel uh and and therefore every time
we just walked out what we got was not
peace we didn't give uh you know
territory for peace we got territory for
Terror that's what we had and that's
what would happen as long as the the
reigning ideology says we don't want
Israel in any border so the the idea of
uh two states assumes that you'd have on
the other side a state that wants to
live in peace and not one that will be
overtaken by Iran and its proxies in two
seconds and become a base to destroy
Israel and therefore I think that most
Israelis today if you ask them uh
they're uh they'd say it's not going to
work in that concept so what do you do
what do you do with the Palestinians
okay they're still there and I don't
unlike them I don't want to throw them
out uh they're going to be living here
and we're going to be living here in an
area which is by the way just to
understand
uh the area the entire area of uh
so-called West Bank and in Israel is the
width of the Washington Beltway more or
less just a little more not much more so
you can't really divide it up you can't
say well you're going to fly in who
controls the airspace well it takes you
about two and a half minutes to cross it
with a with a regular uh you know seven
to four seven okay with the fighter
plane it takes you a minute and a half
okay so you're not how are you going to
divide the airspace well you're not
going to divide it this wheel is going
to control that airspace and the
electromagnetic space uh and uh and so
on so security has to be uh in the hands
of Israel my view of how you solve this
problem is that is a simple principle
the Palestinians should have all the
powers to govern themselves and none of
the powers to threaten Israel which
basically means that the responsibility
for overall security remains with Israel
and from a practice point of view we've
seen that every time that Israel leaves
a territory and and takes its uh
Security Forces out of an area it
immediately is overtaken by hamaso
Hezbollah or jiodist who basically are
committed to the destruction of Israel
and also bring misery to the the
Palestinians or Arab subjects so I think
that that principle is less than perfect
sovereignty
because you're taking a certain amount
of power sovereign powers especially
security away but I think it's the only
practical solution so people say ah but
it's not a perfect State I said okay
call it what you will call it you know
uh I don't know uh limited sovereignty
call it the autonomy plus call it
whatever you want to call it but that's
the reality and right now if you ask
Israelis across the political Spectrum
except the very hard left most Israelis
agree with that they don't really debate
it so two-state solution where Israel
controls the security of the entire
region we don't call it quite that I
mean there are different names but the
idea is yes Israel controls Security in
the is the entire area it's this tiny
area between the Jordan River and the
sea I mean it's like uh you know you can
walk it in not one afternoon if you
really fit you can do it in a in a day
less less than a day I did so the uh
expansion of settlements in the West
Bank has been a top priority for this
new government uh people many harshly
criticize this as contributing to
escalating
the Israel Palestine
can you understand that perspective that
this expansion of settlements is not
good for this two-state solution I can
understand what they're saying and they
don't understand why they're wrong first
the most most Israelis who live in Judea
Samara live in uh in the urban blocks
and that accounts for about 90 percent
of the of the population okay and
everybody recognizes that those Urban
blocs are going to be part of Israel in
any future arrangement so they're really
arguing about something that has already
been decided and agreed upon really by
by Americans by even by Arabs many Arabs
they don't think that Israel is going to
dismantle these these blocks you know
you look outside the window here and
within about a kilometer a mile from
here is you have Jerusalem half of
Jerusalem grew naturally beyond the old
1967 border uh so you're not going to
dismantle half of Jerusalem that's not
going to happen uh and uh and most
people don't expect that then you have
the other uh 10 scattered in tiny uh you
know small communities and people say
well you gotta have to take them out why
why remember that in Pre uh 1967 Israel
we have a over a million and a half
Arabs here we don't say oh Israel has to
be uh ethnically cleansed from Arabs in
order to have from its Arab citizens in
order to have peace of course not Jews
can live among Arabs and Arabs can live
among Jews and what is what is being
Advanced by those people who say that we
can't live in our ancestral Homeland in
these disputed areas nobody says that
this is Palestinian areas and nobody
says that these are israeliers we claim
them they claim them we've only been
attached to this land for oh 3 500 years
but you know but it's a dispute I agree
but I don't agree that we should throw
out the Arabs and I don't think that
they should throw out the Jews and if
somebody said to you the only way we're
going to have peace with Israel is to
have an ethnically cleansed Palestinian
entity you know that that's outrageous
if you said the only way you know you
shouldn't have Jews living in I don't
know in suburbs of London or New York
and so on I don't think that will play
too well the world is actually advancing
a solution that says that uh that Jews
cannot live among Arabs and Arabs cannot
live among Jews I I don't think that's
the right way to do it uh and I I think
there's a solution out there but I don't
think we're going to get to it which is
less than perfect sovereignty which
involves Israeli security uh maintained
for the entire territory by Israel which
involves not rooting out anybody not
kicking out uprooting Arabs or
Palestinians they're going to live in
enclaves in Sovereign Israel and we're
going to live in probably an enclaves
there
probably through transportational
continuity as opposed to territorial
continuity that is uh you know for
example you can have tunnels and
overpasses and so on that connect the
various communities and we're doing that
right now
we're doing that right now and it it
actually works I think there is a
solution to this uh it's not the perfect
world that people think of because that
model I think doesn't apply here
if it applies elsewhere it's a question
uh I don't think so but I think there's
one other thing
and that's the main thing that I've been
involved in
you know people said if you don't solve
the Palestinian problem
you're not going to get to the Arab
world you're not going to have peace
with the Arab world remember the
Palestinians are about two percent of
the Arab world
and the other you know the other 98
you're not going to make peace with them
and that's our goal
and for a long time people accepted that
after the initial peace treaties with
Egypt with the Prime Minister begin of
the likud and and president said out of
Egypt and then uh with Jordan between
prime minister Rabin and uh uh and King
Crusade for quarter of a century we
didn't have any more peace treaties
because people said you got to go
through the Palestinians and the
Palestinians they don't want a solution
of the kind that I described or any kind
except the one that involved the
dissolution of the state of Israel so we
could wait another half century and I
said no I mean I don't think that we
should accept the premise that we have
to wait for the Palestinians because
we'll have to wait forever
so I decided to do it differently I
decided to go directly to the Arab
capitals uh and to make the historic
Abraham Accords uh and essentially uh
reversing the equation not a peace
process that goes inside out
but outside in and we went directly to
the these countries and forged these uh
these breakthrough Peace Accords with
the United Arab Emirates with Bahrain
with Morocco and with Sudan and we're
now trying to expand that in a Quantum
Leap
with Saudi Arabia what does it take to
do that with Saudi Arabia with the Saudi
Crown Prince Muhammad Salman you know
I'm a student of history and I
read a lot of history and I read that uh
you know in the Versailles discussions
after World War one uh President Woodrow
Wilson said I believe in open covenants
openly arrived at I have my correction I
believed in open Covenant secretly
arrived at so there's we're not going to
advance a Saudi Israeli Peace by having
it publicly discussed and in any case
it's a decision of the uh of the Saudis
if they want to do it but there's
obviously a mutual interest so here's my
view
if we try to wait for the two percent in
order to get to the 98 we're going to
fail and we have failed if we go to the
98 we have a much greater chance of
persuading the two percent you know why
because the two percent the Palestinian
uh hope to Vanquish the state of Israel
and not make peace with it is based
among other things on the pro on the
assumption that eventually the 98 the
rest of the Arab world will kick in and
destroy the Jewish State help them
dissolve or destroy the Jewish State
when that hope is
um uh taken away then you begin to have
a turn to the realistic Solutions of
coexistence by the way they'll require
compromise on the Israeli side too and
then you know I'm perfectly cognizant of
that and willing to do that but I think
a realistic compromise will be struck
much more readily when the
conflict between Israel and the Arab
states the Arab world is effectively
solved and I think we're on that path it
was a conceptual change just like you
know I've been involved in a few I told
you the conceptual battle is always the
most difficult one and you know I had to
fight this battle
to convert a semi-social estate into a
free market capitalist State and I have
to say that most people today recognize
the power of competition and the
benefits of free markets so we also had
to fight this battle that's in you have
to go through the you know the the the
the Palestinian uh uh straight
s-t-r-a-i-t to get to the other places
there's no way to avoid this you know
you have to go through this this uh
impassable pass and I think that now
people are recognizing that will go
around it and probably Circle back and
that I think actually gives hope not
only to have an arab-israeli piece but
circling back in israeli-palestinian
piece and obviously this is not
something that you find in the you know
in the sound bites and so on uh but but
in the popular discussion of the press
but that idea is permeating and I think
it's the right idea because I think it's
the only one that will work so expanding
the circle piece just to linger on that
requires what secretly talking
man to man human to Human
uh to leaders of other nations
and theoretically you're right
theoretically okay